The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, OK, OK.
Let's settle down.
Weekend is over.
Tomorrow, weekly quiz.
Today I'll have office
hours 3:00 to 4:00.
I have to go down to Washington,
so I've got to
leave a little bit earlier
than normal.
So I will be available
from 3:00 to 4:00
The lecture has started and
there's still way too much
talking in here.
Way too much.
You know how much is too much?
Any.
So last day, we started talking
about oxide glasses,
and we reasoned that we could
have control of the properties
by control of the composition.
We started with a network
former, which is some oxide
that has the capacity for
forming covalent bonds through
a bridging oxygen.
And then we wanted to drop the
processing temperature, and we
did so by adding modifiers.
Intermediates, we haven't talked
about and we're going
to do that in just a moment.
So if you look in the readings,
this is from
archival notes that were written
by my predecessor,
Professor Witt, these
are compositions of
some typical glasses.
I don't expect you know these
from memory, but I would
expect you, if I gave you the
composition, explain to me why
the various constituents
are there.
So let's try few examples.
The first one is soda-lime
glass.
And you see it contains
silica, which
is the network former.
It contains sodium oxide,
calcium oxide,
and magnesium oxide.
And these are alkaline earth
oxides that are ionic, and so
these are acting as network
modifiers because they're
donating oxide anions
that go in and break
the silicate chains.
And then there's this Al203 and
that's sort of halfway in
between, isn't it?
Silica is Group 4, or
14, if you want to
use the modern notation.
Sodium is Group 1.
Calcium, magnesium, Group 2.
Alumina is Group 3, and it's
sort of halfway in between.
It's amphoteric.
It can either be a former
or a modifier.
And in these instances,
depending on how much modifier
is present, alumina can act
as an intermediate.
And what's an intermediate do?
An intermediate is
a covalent oxide.
It's a covalent oxide, or an
oxide that can act as both
covalent and ionic.
But in this instance, it's
acting covalent oxide with a
different coordination number.
And what does that mean?
Different coordination number?
It coordinates--
remember last day I
showed you B2O3?
Borate glasses?
So they have a coordination
of three, whereas
silicates have four.
And what that means
is that there's
going to be a mismatch.
There's still strong covalent
bonds, but they don't fit
quite right.
And that's going to give
even more free volume.
And that excess free volume,
through covalent bonds, gives
you the ability to endure
thermal shock.
So if you want to impart thermal
shock resistance in a
glass, you give it lots of free
volume so it can take the
rapid change in temperature.
So it's a covalent oxide with
different coordination number.
That is, nearest neighbors, in a
covalent sense, from that of
the network former.
So you can add a borate or
aluminate, what have you.
And that'll give you thermal
shock resistance.
And so alumina here is acting
as an intermediate.
Let's go down here.
There's borosilicate.
borosilicate is the generic
term for Pyrex.
So Pyrex is a trade name.
Pyrex was invented by Corning,
and it contains silica as the
network former.
There's some sodium oxide,
potassium oxide--
in rather small amounts.
You can see this isn't a heavily
modified network, but
look at this.
13% B2O3 and 2% alumina.
That's the modifier.
And what was the hallmark
of Pyrex?
It had thermal shock
resistance.
So you could take it out of the
oven and put it under cold
water and it didn't shatter.
And we have the same analogous
behavior for glass ware in the
laboratory.
For all room temperature and
low temperature work in the
laboratory, we use Pyrex that
has this resistance to
chemicals and resistance
to heat.
This is the big one, here.
And that gave birth to
functional crockery in the
kitchen, where you could work in
glass instead of in metal.
And down here we see glass--
let's see, well, here's one.
Light flint optical.
See, that's 54%.
It's down to 54% silica.
And look at this-- boatloads
of lead oxide.
And the lead oxide is acting as
a modifier and also changes
the index of refraction.
It modifies so much that we
have almost down to the
orthosilicate.
So that the chains are modified
to the point where
they're almost all terminals.
There's very little of this,
and most of it is just
terminal oxygens.
And that means that it's more
nearly crystalline, and
therefore, you can cut it.
And this is the lead crystal.
Lead crystal has that
high value.
So you can see how
that comes out.
And this is also taken
from the reading.
It's a plot of viscosity
versus temperature.
Only it's a logarithmic plot.
And what do you see?
Here's pure silica.
That's SiO2.
And if I want to take it down
to the point where, if the
viscosity goes down, you
have the ability to
work with the glass.
So if I want to melt silica,
I've got to way, way up here.
Over 2,000 Centigrade.
So if I want to make bottles, if
I want to make cookware, I
don't want to run a lehr
at this temperature.
Lehr.
L E H R.
It's where you melt glass.
Lehr.
I don't want to run a lehr
at this temperature.
But you can see if I add
modifier, the more modifier
that I add, the more I
break the network.
So increasing modifier
decreases network
connectivity, and that means I
can go to a lower temperature
and get the same level
of fluidity.
So there's a whole bunch of
definitions here that I'm not
going to go over.
You'll have this slide.
But basically, it's just
different points in
processing.
So if you go up here.
Strain and annealing.
I mean, these are very, very--
you're especially working with
solid, whereas softening
point, you start getting
the glass to flow.
And the working point, that's
the viscosity that
you have to get below.
Otherwise, the glass is going
to be to resistant to flow.
You want to get the glass tacky
so that you can put it
into an injection mold, shape
it, as they do with bottles.
They take a blob of glass and
boom, they just throw it into
a mold and it sprays out.
And if you've got the right mass
and the right spinning,
it makes the wall thickness
proper.
But you can imagine, if the
glass is really, really
viscous, it's not going
to flow well enough.
If it's too fluid, it'll
drip all over.
So there's an optimum
in there.
And this is telling you
how to figure out what
that optimum is.
And you can see that as you
change the composition, here's
the working value.
This is the viscosity that you
have to get below which in
order to work.
And you can see that as you add
more and more modifier,
you can take the temperature
and get it way, way down.
So to work with silica you have
to be about around 2,000.
With soda-lime you can
be down around 800.
So that's going to cut your
energy costs, isn't it?
And it's going to make
it easier to recycle.
What's the point of recycling if
you consume as much energy
to recycle as if you started
with virgin material?
At least with virgin material
you can guarantee the quality
of the feeds stock.
So there's got to be
some big saving.
All right.
So that gives you a some sense
as to what we can do
technologically with glasses.
I want to show you one last
thing with glasses, and then
we're going to move on
to another topic.
You know, new week, new
day, new topic.
So I want to go back
to this curve.
So what am I showing you here?
I'm showing you that as we
change the cooling rate, we
change the amount of quenched-in
excess volume.
So fast cooling quenches in more
of the liquid free volume
than slow cooling does.
That's why this V excess is
small here, whereas V excess
is large here for
the other one.
I'm going to use that in
glass strengthening.
So I want to strengthen.
Strengthening glasses.
We're talking about silicates
or borates.
Strengthening oxide glasses.
Glass is a fantastic material.
It's really good in compression,
but it's no good
in tensions.
You know this.
If you try to bend glass,
it'll break.
Why?
Not because it doesn't
have dislocations.
It's got strong covalent
bonds.
But you know, suppose you want
to strengthen the windshield
of your car so that
when a stone hits
it, it doesn't shatter.
What can we do to give
it added strength?
So I'm going to show you two
ways, and both of them operate
under this principle that
the yield stress--
this is the stress that will
break the glass, and I'm going
to say the effective yield
stress, what you
experience in life--
is equal to the sum of what I'm
going to call the natural
yield stress, which is the basic
property of the glass.
Plus, I'm going to increase
the surface stress.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to modify the surface,
and I'm going to put an
additive stress at the
surface, and that's going to
be a compressive stress.
So that means now the effective
stress that I need
to break the glass is going
to be greater than it
otherwise would be.
So the whole gambit here is
surface strengthening.
Service strengthening, which
means surface modification.
And I'm going to show you two
ways to modify the surface to
bring the strength
of the glass up.
The first way is thermal.
Thermal treatment.
And the thermal treatment is
to strengthen the glass.
Well, let's see.
Let's keep it in the context
of the windshield.
The technical term
for this, the
technological term is tempering.
So what I'm going to show you
was how we can look at that
volume versus temperature curve
and understand how we
make tempered glass for
windshields and so.
So I'm going to show you
a slab of glass.
Here's a slab of glass.
And we just got below the
softening point-- so T just
less than T softening.
So now this thing's going to
start, it's continuing to
become more and more viscous and
getting closer and closer
to glass transition
temperature.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to introduce air
jets at the surface
of the glass.
What that's going to do
is it's going to cause
accelerated cooling
at the surface.
And the same thing happens on
both surfaces, so I'm going to
cut this piece of glass in half,
and we're just going to
look at the upper surface.
The same thing happens
in a lower surface.
So let's now blow this up.
I'm just going to look at the
upper-half surface and I'm
going to divide it
into two zones.
This is the first level,
most primitive
finite element analysis.
Finite element analysis.
I'm going to divide it in two,
and I'm going to say, this has
got two zones.
Two cooling zones.
Here is the zone of
the center, OK?
This is the center.
And I'm going to call this
the inner portion.
And then there's the
outer portion.
Well, take a look at
this curve here.
Which is going to have
slower cooling?
In the center or near
the free surface?
The slower cooling is in the
center and according to this
graph, the slow cooling has
a smaller residual volume.
I've written, V-interior.
That's the green line.
And then the upper one
is a yellow line.
So the upper one where it's high
cooling, it's going to
have a higher volume.
So this is the second piece
of finite element.
So I'm going to model
this one like so.
So this is outer.
And the same thing happens
on the other side, OK?
So it's happening on
the bottom as well.
But we're just looking
at the top because
there's symmetry here.
So you see what I've done?
This is longer because that
graph says it wants to be
occupying a larger volume.
Problem is the glass
can't do this.
I can do this with a piece of
chalk, but the glass isn't
going to look like that.
The glass is going to
have a flat edge.
And how can it have
a flat edge?
Because the bottom, here-- this
is not to scale, let's
make it more to scale--
the top is a narrow zone and
the bottom is a big, thick
zone, isn't it?
So this big, thick zone, which
has a small volume, is going
to pull on the thin upper
zone, which has a large
volume, and pull it in.
Can you see that?
And it's going to cause
the introduction
of compressive stresses.
So we got to compressive
stresses simply using that
graph and a little bit of air.
So you take that graph, put
differential cooling, and now
you've introduced compressive
stress.
And that's all tempered
glass is.
So the V-excess of the outer
layer is greater than V-excess
of the inner layer, or the
interior, if you like.
And why?
Because the cooling rate, the
change of temperature with
time of the outer zone, is
greater than the cooling rate
of the inner or interior.
And there it is.
That's the beginning.
And so now to fracture you have
to apply a greater stress
then you would have otherwise.
So that's good, and that
saves a lot of lives.
There's another way.
There's another way to surface
strengthen, and that's a
chemical treatment.
And again, what am
I trying to do?
I'm trying to introduce a
compressive stress, but I'm
going to use a chemical means.
And this one is called
ion exchange.
And this is used in
technology, too.
So now I'm going to take
a piece of glass here.
This is solid glass and let's
put some components in here.
So I'm going to put some silica
as my network former.
I'm going to put some
sodium oxide.
And I'm going to put some
modifier, B2O3.
So I got all three here.
Former, modifier,
intermediate.
And just to put a little skin
on the bones here, I want to
show what the sodium oxide
actually looks like.
Sodium oxide goes in as sodium
cations, and oxide anions.
The oxide anions go in
and they break some
of the silica chains.
But the sodiums don't get
involved in that.
They just sit around
as spectators.
Now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to put this, I'm
going to soak this
in molten salt.
Soak in molten salt.
This is huge area of
my own research.
And the molten salt, one example
might be I'm going to
take potassium chloride.
Remember, we talked about making
aluminum or magnesium?
This is one of the constituents
of the melt in
which we make electrolytic
magnesium.
Potassium chloride.
And it exists as potassium
cations and chloride anions.
Chlorine is green,
except we know--
you know, this is the way
chemistry books write it, but
that's stupid because this is
isoelectronic with argon.
And it's not green.
I know.
I've looked at this stuff.
It's clear, colorless,
and transparent.
The chloride ion has to be
clear and colorless.
It's got a complete shell,
but the chemistry books
will make it green.
Anyway, here's the potassium
ion here.
And there's a lot of
potassium ion here.
There's no potassium ion
inside the glass.
There's sodium ion in the glass,
there's no sodium ion
in the molten salt.
But these are both media
in which ions live.
So can you see this is sort of
like the perfume bottle?
Things move from high
concentration to low
concentration.
Some sodium wants to leave
and enter the melt.
And some potassium wants
to leave the melt
and enter the glass.
And where's the potassium
going to go?
It has to go where there
used to be sodium.
What's the relative size
of potassium ion
versus sodium ion?
Potassium ion is bigger.
So potassium ion goes and
occupies a site formerly
occupied by sodium and causes
compressive stress, because
you get all these big ions
jamming in there and that's
going to lead to compressive
stress through ion exchange.
So through ion exchange we
can raised the temp.
Since r, the radius of potassium
is greater than the
radius of the sodium, we get a
force fit, and this is how we
got solution hardening.
Hardening is the metallurgical
term for raising the strength.
Hardening is equal to
strength going up.
So we get hardening
by solution.
So this is solution hardening.
Solution hardening because the
potassium ion is in there.
So we have surface.
And this gives a lot
of strength.
We do the same thing
metallurgically if you
carburize the surface
of a piece of steel.
Tool steels, for example,
surface carburized.
So we get hard surfaces
that can cut.
You say, well, why don't you
just put the carbon in all the
way through?
Well, then the tool bit
will be brittle.
So you want something that's got
toughness in the center so
it can take the impact,
but it's got surface
hardness so it'll cut.
And that's an engineered
material.
We've got one set of properties
at the surface, and
we've got another set of
properties in the bulk.
And it's all brought to you
by control of chemistry.
And then that's also control
of chemistry.
OK.
So I mean, I could talk more
and more and more.
Glasses are just fascinating
things.
But we've got to get moving.
So we're going to move
to a new topic.
We're going to move to
a new topic today.
We're going to start talking
about kinetics.
Kinetics.
And what is kinetics?
Kinetics is the topic that we
put into 3.091, because it's
important, of course, but it's
all about the study of
reaction rates.
It's the study of reaction
rates and mechanism.
So why do we study?
Well, we study it because
I think it belongs here.
But first of all, kinetics is
related to productivity and
resource utilization.
You've got two factories.
One produces 200 units per time,
the other produces 100
units per time.
The one that's producing 100
units per time probably isn't
going to be in business
that much longer.
And it's all about understanding
how to get more
throughput per unit time, and
that leads to competitiveness.
So if you're interested in
international competitiveness,
you've got to know something
about kinetics.
The two go hand in glove.
Second thing is energy
and the environment.
A number of you have come to
talk to me after class, sent
emails because you're interested
in energy and the
environment.
Efficient use of energy involves
understanding the
kinetics so you can force
chemical change with the least
amount of energy utilization and
do so in a way because its
mechanism--
if there's two mechanisms that
allow you to get to the same
end product, choose the one
that has the least toxic
impact on the environment.
Otherwise, you're going to have
to spend money to avoid
the effluents, which then gets
you back up to number one.
Your cost of doing business is
higher than the other guy.
Guess what?
You're creamed in
the marketplace.
And lastly, societal.
And this is one that excites
me, is kinetics leads to
productivity, which keeps
factories open, which keeps
people working.
So through understanding
kinetics.
You go and you look at places
in the United States where
factories have closed.
In many, many instances it was
because the technology lagged.
If you could just keep
things going faster.
You've got to make things-- you
know how fast you've got
to make them go?
You've got to make them go so
fast that even if the foreign
workers are paid zero, you can
still beat them in the
marketplace.
That's your standard.
So that's how you design
your processes.
You design your processes so
that you can produce at very,
very low cost.
And there's a huge range
in reaction rates.
You know, you can start
the range of
rates, rates of reaction.
At the one that you have
very, very slow.
And way over here you have very,
very fast, all right?
So on the slow end, you
have stuff that's
sort of cosmic scale.
Geological.
And then over here,
what do we have?
We have explosions.
You might say, well, explosions
are usually bad,
aren't they?
Well, no.
I can give you an example of
where explosion is used to
your advantage.
The airbag in the automobile.
There is no pump, no mechanical
pump fast enough to
inflate an airbag on demand.
So how do we make those
airbags work?
And I hope none of us ever
has to be present at the
deployment of those airbags.
But you know, just academically
let's talk about
how they work.
There's like an explosion that
occurs when you're driving.
There's an accelerometer and
this is a key piece.
The accelerometer has to make
a decision whether you're
applying the brakes just because
you've lost focus and
you're, you know, whoops!
You've had that jerky brake.
Or maybe this is one of those
holy-mackerel moments, and
your jamming on the
brakes, and we'd
better deploy the airbags.
Once the accelerometer decides
that this is one of those holy
you-know-what moments, it sends
an electric current
through a wire, which then
raises the temperature to 300
degrees C and causes this
reaction to take place.
When this reaction takes
place, this is a solid,
nitrogen is a gas.
So the gas has a much, much
higher volume than the solid
and within milliseconds
you get inflation.
Well, that's good and that
inflates the bag and prevents
you from hitting the hard
parts of the car.
But you see the other
byproduct?
That's sodium.
And if you look on your Periodic
Table, elemental
sodium is liquid above
98 degrees Celsius.
So now you've got
liquid sodium.
There's no point preserving the
safety of the occupants of
the car just to cover them
with liquid sodium.
So we better do something
about that.
So being chemists, what we do
is we add potassium nitrate
inside the bag, as well.
so.
That that sodium is mopped up
with potassium nitrate, which
converts it to sodium oxide,
potassium oxide, and a little
more nitrogen.
[BLOWING SOUND EFFECT]
Keep the bag nice and firm.
But now what happens when the
Fires show up and they
[SOUND EFFECT],
you know, they start pouring
water on it.
This turns into caustic.
So now you're going to get
covered and wet lye.
So that's probably not
too good, either.
Just remember, you've been
physically saved from smashing
your skull on the tempered
windshield.
So it's so far, so good.
So now what?
You want a mechanical, you
want a Newtonian death?
Or do you want a Coulombic
death?
I guess that's the
question, here.
And so we're going to keep doing
some chemistry here and
we're going to add silica.
And what happens if we add
silica to sodium oxide
potassium oxide?
Well that's a network former,
these are network modifiers.
We'll make an alkaline silicate
glass and that's OK
because we put food
and beverages in
alkaline silicate glasses.
So everybody is happy.
So that's all the chemistry that
goes on inside an airbag.
And we've got to understand
the kinetics.
So I hope I've whet
your appetite.
OK, that's enough of that.
Now let's get to
the real stuff.
So let's write a general
chemical reaction.
The general reaction.
What's the formalism if we want
to set up the metrics?
So I'm going to write just
a plain, old equation.
This is the classical
P-Chem stuff.
Little a moles of A, plus little
b moles of B go to
little c moles of C plus
little d moles of D.
So this could have
been lecture two.
Just a straight chemical
reaction.
Remember we were studying
stoichiometry?
So the constituents of the left
side of the equation are
called the reactants, whereas
on the right side of the
equation we have the products.
And what kinetics gives us,
kinetics tells us the rate of
conversion.
Or the rate of reaction.
I'm using all these terms
so you understand their
equivalent.
So we can write something like
this where the conservation of
mass kicks in.
So I can't make products
any faster
than I consume reactants.
There's no sources
or sinks here.
When I lose reactants,
I make products.
So I'm going to say, the rate of
change of the total mass of
the reactants-- this
is summation sign--
I'm just saying the rate of
change of the sum of all of
the reactions must equal
the rate of change.
So the loss rate of reactants
must equal the gain rate of
all of the products.
That's just simple
stoichiometry.
Or some people call this
conservation of mass or Law of
Mass Action, what have you.
And then we count by
concentration, usually.
Just reminder.
This is lowercase c.
So this is the concentration
of species i
goes as the mole number.
n is mole number divided by
the volume of the reactor.
So this would be in moles
per meter cubed if
we were in SI units.
So therefore the rate of change,
the ci by dt, is
really the rate of change of
mole number, isn't it?
It's moles of i disappearing,
but the volume
doesn't change, typically.
And then the last thing is we
can use this idea up here that
concentration of products can
only equal the loss rate of
the reactant.
So I can write, term by term,
the normalized rate loss of
the concentration of a divided
by its stoichiometric
coefficient, for example, would
equal the normalized
weight gain, or pardon me, the
concentration gain of the
concentration of d.
So this is just saying a
disappears no faster than d
appears, mediated by the
stoichiometric coefficients.
So this is just Law of Mass
Action, which is stoichiometry
in motion, isn't it?
That's all it is.
Now here comes the cool
thing kinetic theory.
We look at any reaction, I can
tell you right now what it
looks like.
If I applied concentration of
i as a function of time, I
start off with some value c
naught, some initial value,
and it just attenuates.
We know that's going to happen
as we consume the-- it falls
and there's some
curvature here.
What we're trying to do next is
to give some mathematical
representation to this.
Can we come up with a
mathematical formulation of
the shape of that curve?
And we can, and here's
the central
tenet kinetic of theory.
Kinetic theory says that the
reaction rate can be expressed
in terms of a driving force.
And that driving force is the
instant concentration.
OK.
These are lofty words.
I'll show you what it means
with illustration.
So that's the overall idea.
So now let's say that the rate
of change, the instant rate of
change of concentration ci, is
proportional to the instant
value of the concentration.
And you know, the concentration
is changing, right?
As the concentration
decreases, the
rate of change decreases.
So just this alone, this idea
alone would rationalize a
curve like that.
As the concentration falls,
the rate of change falls,
which means the concentration
falls, which means--
and raised to some power--
it's not linear, necessarily--
raised to some power.
There's a power law
at work here.
So now let's do this
one more time.
I'm going to write it
mathematically.
But I want you to first see
the word, concepts.
So let's write it
mathematically.
That means minus dci by dt--
so this is time rate a change of
concentration i, the minus
means it's falling--
is equal to the concentration
of i raised to some power n.
This is order reaction.
It's not mole number
over there.
You've got to be pluralistic
today.
n is going to be used
in different ways.
So this is called order
of reaction.
And there's a constant.
See up there?
It's a proportionality.
Here it's an equal sign,
thanks to the constant.
And this is called the
rate constant.
And this what all I need
for plant design.
Suppose I'm running a chemical
plant and I'm taking a plus b
and making c plus d and the
management says, we want to
double the rate of
productivity.
So you go, I know what to do.
We'll increase the
concentration.
They say, by how much?
Well, this allows you, if you
know the value of k and n, you
want to double this?
Then you know what to do here.
It's not necessarily double
the concentration, Because
this is a 1.5 power.
By the way, this doesn't
have to be an integer.
Could be anything.
Could be not necessarily integer
and must be determined
by experiment.
You can't look at an equation
and say, oh, that's going to
be second order because
there's a
two in front of something.
So here we are, plant
designers.
And the management wants
to know, how do
we make things happen?
So I'm going to go back to that
equation over there and
I'll say that most generally,
the rate of change of
concentration of a will then go
as rate constant times the
concentration of a.
See, the rate of change
goes as something
to the power alpha.
But it could also be
influenced by b.
So I'm going to put-- this
is the most general form.
Then once you make your
measurements, a lot
of these fall out.
I'm even going to put c
I'm going to put d.
Everything was in
that equation.
You might say, well,
wait a minute.
How can the rate of consumption
of a be influenced
by the concentration of d?
d is a product.
I'll give you two examples.
One is that d, when I'm making
d, d happens to have some
catalytic value.
So when I start making a convert
to d, d catalyzes the
reaction, which makes it go
faster, which makes more d,
which makes the reaction go
faster, in which case this is
going to have a profound
effect.
And unfortunately, there are
some other situations where a
converts to d and d retards
the reaction.
And so I start off with pretty
decent conversion efficiency,
but as I make more and more d,
the d chokes the reaction, in
which case the value here is
going to have negative
implications.
So that's why you write it most
generally, and then you
go and you make some
measurements in an experiment,
and you figure out
what these are.
Some of them might be zeroes,
and away you go.
So I'll give you an
example of one.
Here's one.
It's Monday after Halloween,
so we'll get
something kind of toxic.
This was the manufacture of
phosgene that was banned by
international convention.
It was used as one of the toxic
gases for trench warfare
in World War I.
So it's made by the
reaction of carbon
monoxide and chlorine.
COCL2.
This is called phosgene.
It's very bad stuff.
I used it, actually,
in my research.
It has really good dehydration
properties for salts.
If you've got any moisture in
potassium chloride, this'll go
after it and turn the water into
carbon dioxide and HCl.
But you've got to be really,
really careful with this.
Gas leaks lead to a bad
day at the lab.
All right, this was banned.
It's still use by tyrants
throughout the world, and
that's why we have international
war tribunals.
So here's the kinetics of it.
Here's the kinetics of it.
dc by dt.
So this is the rate of
consumption of carbon monoxide
determined by experiment goes as
the concentration of carbon
monoxide and the concentration
of chlorine raised
to the power 3/2.
So what I've done
is mimic here.
So in this case, gamma
and delta are 0.
Gamma equals delta equals 0, and
it looks like beta equals
1.5 and alpha equals 1.
So I would say that this
reaction is first order in
carbon monoxide of order
1.5 in chlorine, or
overall, of order 2.5.
Because, right?
This is the order of reaction.
This is c to the power
1, isn't it?
We don't write the 1.
This is great.
So we know, to increase the rate
of reaction we increase
the concentration.
There's another way to increase
the rate of reaction.
What else can we do to increase
the rate of reaction?
Increase the temperature.
Things go faster at higher
temperatures.
Again, how?
How much?
Suppose I said, I want to double
the rate of reaction.
Do I double the temperature?
Do I raise the temperature
by 10 degrees?
How do I do that?
So to increase rate of reaction,
we can increase
temperature.
But how?
And by the way, where
is temperature here?
I don't see temperature.
I don't see temperature
in this rate equation.
You could say, well, if you
increase the temperature
you're going to increase
the gas volume.
But that's piddling
effect, right?
If I double the temperature,
I double the gas volume.
It doesn't change
the mole number.
The temperatures in here.
That's where the temperature.
Increase temperature,
which then
operates on the rate constant.
That's the only place left
in that formalism.
But what's the quantitative
value?
Quantitative value was
annunciated to us in 1889 by
the Swedish chemist Arrhenius.
And what Arrhenius found, he
found that the rate constant
varied with temperature in
the following manner.
Rate constant goes as the
exponential of the ratio of
minus some quantity call the
activation energy e sub a--
I'm going to tell you what
that means in a minute--
divided by the ratio of the
product of the Boltzmann
constant and temperature.
And there's a constant of
proportionality which we
denote A in honor
of Arrhenius.
Or another way to write this
is A times exponential--
are you familiar with this?
Instead of writing e to the
something, if there's a messy
argument up here you
can write it exp.
This is the same as this minus
ea over the ratio of Boltzmann
constant and temperature.
So what's in here?
What's in here?
Boltzmann constant temperature,
we've seen that already.
What's the Boltzmann constant
temperature product?
That's the environment.
That's the energy of
the environment.
So this is the final
environment.
And this thing up on top,
ea, is a barrier.
It's a barrier.
Remember we saw the band gap?
Same idea.
Those ideas go all through
physical chemistry.
You got thermal energy that
allows you to do this 10
trillion times a second.
Everybody in this room
is doing this 10
trillion times a second.
That's what kT is.
And then there's a
barrier energy.
Every once in a while
something happens.
Sometimes one in a million,
sometimes one in a billion.
Whatever.
What Arrhenius found was this
relationship, which means we
could plot the variation
of the rate constant.
This is a mess, right?
This is an exponential--
look, the eye can only
see straight lines.
What if I show you this?
What's that mean?
I don't know.
Is that first order?
Second order?
Is that Lagrangian?
Is that exponential?
I don't know.
I know it's a curve.
But what's this?
I know what that is.
And you know what that is.
And you can tell goodness
of fit.
This is what science
is all about.
Forget all the other stuff.
You know, all that UROP stuff.
You're going to work in a
lab and discover stuff.
Forget that.
This is what it's about.
You got data.
Data are all over the map.
Here's the thing--
I need to come up with some
f function here versus a g
function here that linearize
my data.
That's all science is about.
And how do I get to f and g?
Well, there's two ways.
One is trial and error.
The other way is physical
understanding.
And this is what Arrhenius
taught us.
Arrhenius taught us that the f
function for how k varies with
temperature, right?
The problem, I'm trying
to say, k versus t.
That's what I'm trying to do.
And if I plot k versus
t I get a curve.
No good.
Instead, if I plot some f of
k versus g of t, I get a
straight line.
And this is all science.
So what's f of k?
The natural logarithm
of k, right?
If I've got k equals a
exponential, I take the
natural log of this, and the
natural log of an exponential
is just the argument.
And what's in the argument?
What's the T function?
1 over T.
So if I plot the natural log of
k versus the reciprocal of
the absolute temperature, I get
a straight line and its
slope is minus ea, forgive me,
minus ea over k-Boltzmann.
Minus ea over k-Boltzmann.
So now it's linearized and I can
look at that and within an
instant, anybody in this room
can look at and say, the data
conform or they don't.
They don't.
So now let's think about this.
We say well, what's the
value of this barrier?
It's called activation energy.
This barrier energy is called
activation energy.
ea is called the activation
energy.
And it typically, it varies,
but it has values--
just to give you a sense--
about 1 electron volt.
1 electron volt, which you
know now is about 100
kilojoules per mole, isn't it?
I hear the chorus of yesses.
1 electron volt.
What is thermal energy?
What's kT?
kT at room temperature,
k-Boltzmann at room
temperature is about 1/40
of an electron volt.
Now, we are chemical machines.
This conversation is occurring
because all sorts of chemical
processes are at work
in me and you.
And how's that happening?
When all we've got to suck out
of the environment is 1/40 of
an electron volt and we need on
the order one electron volt
to drive certain processes.
I guess we're all dead.
Any ideas?
Ay yay, yay.
You guys need--
what's that thing?
You've got to call your
lifeline or something?
Come on.
How does anything happen?
How do we get--
Why does anything happen
in this world?
Why should anything happen in a
world with an environment of
1/40 of an electron volt?
AUDIENCE: Catalysts.
PROFESSOR: Oh, catalysts.
Catalysts.
Yeah, yeah.
I just went to the catalyst
store and I got catalysts.
Come on.
AUDIENCE: Potential energy.
PROFESSOR: Oh, potential
energy.
Jeez, this is good.
Who can give me the
wackiest answer?
Can anybody give me
the right answer?
How come anything
is happening?
Over here.
Again?
AUDIENCE: Distribution
of temperature.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Thank you.
For a moment I thought
we were all dead.
At some level we were.
So, yeah, it's
Maxwell-Boltzmann.
It's this, isn't it?
And here's room temperature.
And here is 1 electron volt.
And this is it.
And if you use this and you put
it back to there, pretty
soon you derive the Arrhenius
equation.
And if you increase
the temperature
you know what happens.
After you increase the
temperature, this.
Time to use a hot
color or chalk.
So now this is T2
greater than T1.
That's what's going on.
So now what is this
activation energy?
What is the meaning of it?
You know, I've told you there's
a barrier energy.
What does it mean?
Well, you go to the textbook,
you see goofy stuff like this.
And this is not a slam
against the textbook.
This is a slam against all
chemistry textbooks, because
they all write this
stupid stuff.
You see? a plus b goes c plus
d, the energy falls and you
have to go over this
activated complex.
You memorize it, and I ask you
to repeat, it and we leave the
room and we think, wow, we
know physical chemistry.
There's nothing here.
This is nothing.
This is stupid.
Now this is a little
bit better.
Can you see this?
This is the Maxwell-Boltzmann.
This is actually a beautiful
graph up to a point.
See the Maxwell-Boltzmann?
Low temperature, high
temperature.
Only they've turned this
thing on its side.
See?
And there's the energy
you need to get over
the activated complex.
You see what's wrong
with this graph?
What's wrong with it?
AUDIENCE: The product.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the product
is at a higher
level than the reactants.
I looked at that and
I thought, whoa!
I guess you'll activate them,
but they won't go anywhere.
Anyway, so this is all stupid.
What can we do?
So I decided to give you
a mechanical analogy.
So imagine this is
the loudspeaker.
Can you say the x?
People in the back,
can you see the x?
Give me a thumbs up.
Great eyes.
All right.
So what do we see here?
The center of mass, I've
indicated here.
All right.
So this is in a certain
energy state.
Let's get the right
graph up there.
This is awful.
All right.
So this is a plus b.
Now this is c plus d.
You see, the center
of mass fell.
It's lower.
It's closer to the table
than it is here.
Can you see when I go like
this, the photon goes?
Watch this.
Yeah, only I can see it.
Your eyes don't go to that
end of the spectrum.
All right.
But what's wrong with it?
So why does the box
not fall over?
Why does it not fall over?
We agreed that this is a lower
energy state, and it is.
You're correct.
So why does the box manage to
stay here and not fall over?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
This is the box at 0 Kelvin.
Now we start raising the energy
of the box, it starts
doing this.
Because above 0 Kelvin,
it vibrates.
The higher the temperature,
the greater the vibration.
But we're still in trouble here,
you see, because you've
only got 1/40 of an
electron volt.
So now we invoke distribution.
I don't know what's happening
with any box.
Heisenberg tells me that.
I don't know what's happening
to any box.
But if I take Avogadro's number
of boxes I'll get this
distribution.
And some boxes will vibrate
very little.
And some boxes will
vibrate a lot.
And what's the critical
level of vibration?
It's to get to here.
Because once it gets to here
it's downhill all the way.
And that would be the
activation energy.
And the fraction of boxes that
get to the value of activation
energy tip over and then I
restore the distribution,
because now this one's out of
the game and now I distribute
that energy over the
remaining ones.
And as I increase the
temperature, the amplitude of
the vibration increases, the
average increases, the
fraction in that red zone
increases, and at some
temperature it's so, so hot that
they actually do this, in
which case I have equilibrium.
The two states are
in equilibrium.
So that's it.
This is what's going on.
So in three space, you can't go
from here to here without
going to here.
You can try going this way so
you-- no, you have to do this.
It still has to be mechanically
activated so we
can show that this is what
activation means.
So we can plot--
this deserves it's own board--
so we will plot something
like this.
And now you'll see this.
Sometimes they write
this in the books.
It's kind of goofy.
But they write stuff
like this.
This is some kind of an
energy coordinate.
This is an energy coordinate.
And this is called a reaction
coordinate.
OR sometimes they write
extent of reaction.
Again, some P-Chem term.
They usually use Greek C just
to make it lofty, but it's
meaningless.
And then so you write like
this-- reactants here,
products here, and this is
exactly what we're seeing.
What do we see?
We see this.
Here we have the box
sitting like so.
And then over here we have
the box sitting like so.
And right here we have
the box up like so.
And so now you have, here's
the initial energy.
This is the energy
of the reactants.
E of the reactants.
This is E of the products.
So then this distance
here must be
delta E of the reaction.
And what's this?
That's the activation energy.
I have to come up with this;
otherwise, I can't make the
box fall over.
So this is ea to go from here
up onto the corner.
And now you understand what
all this stuff means.
So that's here.
And this is the activated
complex.
What's an activated complex?
It's a box on its edge
ready to fall over.
That's what it is.
All right.
I think we're out of time, so
let's cut to the end here.
What've we got.
Oh, just some plots.
We'll get to that next day.
All right.
So I want to show
you a little bit
about first-order reactions.
This is radiocarbon dating.
n equals 1.
And strictly speaking, this is
not a chemical reaction, but
it is first order.
So I'll lump it in here.
So this is a nuclear reaction.
And what happens in the
upper atmosphere?
Radioactive carbon produced by
cosmic rays, which generate
neutrons in the upper atmosphere
and then those
neutrons attack nitrogen
to make carbon 14.
That's the radioactive
form of carbon.
Remember?
It's present in one part per
trillion, if you look on your
Periodic Table for
the isotopes.
Now carbon 14 enters
the carbon cycle.
And so in all of us and in all
living organisms the ratio of
carbon 14 to carbon 12 is
one part per trillion.
And carbon 13 is also present.
I don't know.
What is it?
1 point something percent?
The thing is, the carbon
14 is radioactive.
And it decays.
Like this.
But what happens after
somebody dies?
Well, they stop exchanging
nutrients with the
surroundings.
They stop breathing, so their
carbon level is pegged as it
was at the time of death.
And now it's a one0way street.
It's just carbon decay.
And it turns out you can measure
the ratio of carbon 14
to carbon 12 to determine the
age, which is given by 5,730
years, which is the inverse
of the rate constant.
Now, you can't use this for
crime scene investigations,
but certainly you can start
dating things hundreds of
years old, not hundreds
of minutes old.
So there's a whole bunch of
other things that can be used,
not just carbon.
So this is radiochemical
dating.
And these are used in trying to
nail down art forgeries and
all sorts of things.
All right.
So here, you can see these.
These have all been
radiocarbon dated.
You know, the Dead Sea Scrolls
were radiocarbon dated and
they look like they're from
about 2,000 years ago.
Makes sense.
You go out over here.
They they found these Indian
sandals from Oregon, and then
they looked on an electron
microscope, and they found
something on the sandals that
looks a little bit like that.
That's a Nike swoosh.
I don't know.
You people are so--
All right.
So now I want to show you
the Shroud of Turin.
The Shroud of Turin, as you may
know, for a long time was
reputed to be the burial shroud
of Jesus Christ. And
this is taken from the National
Geographic back in
the late '80s.
Back in the late '80s, they
did a major study on it.
So this is the artist rendition
of how the shroud
might have been wrapped
around a body.
The question is, what's
the date of this?
So we can use radiocarbon
dating.
And so here's the formation
of carbon 14.
Carbon 14 exchanges with
carbon 12 in flax.
So it's got one part
per trillion.
When the flax is harvested the
carbon 14 starts to decay.
And then we look at
the weaving of the
shroud and so on.
And they had three different
labs, they took samples from
the shroud.
And they concluded
that the shroud
dates from this period--
1260 to 1390.
And the first time it was
mentioned in the literature
was around 1354.
So everything seems to make
sense that this is not the
burial shroud of Jesus Christ.
It's something that has
importance to certain members of
the Roman Church, but it's
scientifically not.
You know, this stirs up
a lot of passion.
So people started saying,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
There was a fire in 1532 and
people repaired the shroud and
they were using candlelight
and maybe the paraffin and
mold and so on covered
the fibers.
So now, are we looking at
the surface effect?
How do we know what
really happened?
The only way to know is to take
the whole shroud, put in
a big Cuisinart and break
open the interior.
Well, in point of fact, what
they did was take fibers and
look inside.
And I think as of the late '90s,
the Roman Church says,
it's not the burial shroud
of Jesus, but it is
an object of reverence.
And I think it's a good
example of how science
sometimes comes up against
spirituality, and we have to
be careful how we handle it.
It's a delicate matter.